nd
ana
Phalanx In ancient Greece, it's a 3-circle formation with a lot of ferocity.
Wow,
it's suspicious that Kosaka is alone at night.
I've never
heard of that kind of work tomorrow because it's an important battle
.  It's the same as the world give me
[music]
me
ran
mai yeah yeah
yeah
[music]
n ame
oath of the cup
]
Wow, this is more than I'm
gonna go ah ah ah
[music]
Amazingly reorganized
Phalanx formation
That's not what I thought of
Amazing is going Alexander the Great and Nobunaga Oda Mine
is just a tweet
Okay, obviously the enemy is floating  Oh
no, I'll decide here
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh  This savage house day
[music]
I climbed up to the twin trees leading the clan of
wolves One instruction 0 A position that determines someone's life or death
Get away from me
Apparently who's over there?
Is it possible that you will marry me?
diner I told you about
my worries.
Are you injured or something?
Even though I didn't go to the front line, my brother didn't do anything.
Rather, Rune is fine
.  It
must have been hard work What is
good for mating?
Well, don't say that,
I'm
a mid-ranking midfielder, so I'm going to the
ground.
Alright, I'm preparing for the tent Harley meeting
.
If you say it, it's a
wolf's performance.
It's better to generalize Why is it that you talk in your sleep? It's
true that we were dogs before,
but Barrera was reborn because of his brother.
5 The insult to the ground that shows that it is a thing is u San
U. Both of them to the dentist-she
plays Snow in some way, but the rude mouth is
restrained.
If you use a high-handed attitude to make people feel disgust, they'll take a liking to those who reach out a helping hand.
That's what I said
, what about
younger sisters?
This is the first and last information for younger
sisters.  Let's put the city in front of the version of the city
Oh, do you want
to put on and take off another one
Do you want to do 1?
[Music]
If that's the case, it won't turn out like this
.
Father, are you okay? No matter how you're feeling, I
'm just tired
.  Chichu is actually a very merciful person, but
I don't care if it's part of the house, I'm
just sweet
.
I think it's very precious
Please don't blame yourself too much
Thank you for always stopping Thank
you w I'm the one
who summoned my brother to this world, so
I haven't sent the stew to the public prosecutor
[Music]  ] There's
rules too, so
let's go home
.
Thank you, I was praying for the Meiwa 3-angle border pattern and victory in the battle
.  I'll say later,
instead, isn't that attitude towards the characters
too rude?  It's from Paris,
right?
I won't
ask Thank you Persia Bach Yes, I should have put more effort into responding Kita
I'm going,
I found a
way to change it.
1300 to 2000 B.C.E.
So the earth in the late Bronze Age,
because the catchers seen from the ground were exactly the same
.
Good morning to the ground Good morning brother
Breakfast
Thanks to you, I can bake delicious bread every day
Father really has a mysterious wisdom
Thanks to smartphone
If it's okay with me, I'll start sewing thread to tie it right now
.
I'm going to kill you because it's uneconomical.
If you solve it with that, it
's a test.The more you paint, the more you'll get 1
Dion rolled up.The whole
house is a poor storehouse.
You can do anything when you're
hungry If you learn how to make it in a book, you can do 6 threads about various flavors while you're at
it.
Well then
ah ah ah well
it's been a while Ingrid
won't be surprised so far
it's been a long time
Do you really care about things like that? People say that I
'll take a c life and
heal it.  I've got to be careless
Ah
, this guy from before, John,
ecchi 10 yen
When I knew it, I
couldn't get rid of Suzuki's quirks even when I was a goo
Excuse me Nets
I don't care if you call each other by name when you're alone,
Hawaii Don't take it in a strange way Let's make
something together again  That's what it means in the
future, if the Tsuno general office becomes my designation, and if the
Tsuno who becomes my younger sister becomes the designation,
I think there will be times when I will use the same weapon, is
n't that
right
?  I'm sure you're going to be busy, but please
don't
ask in glitter.
Grail relationships are more absolute than blood ties, and through the sacred ritual of the Holy Grail, Tsuyasushiko and designation are
bound by a strong bond,
which is
how this world has become.  A wolf should be able to enjoy peaceful days.In other
words, if you stay, you can find a way to return to the original world without worrying
about it.
Finally, tell me how many times to say 4 episodes, and treat the
horns like civilian wolves
.
I'll listen to your cute selfishness for
free
Brother, what's
going on, Felicia?
It is said that the Clan Tei
launched an invasion of the town of Daikokukaku and took down the fort along its border.
But
there's no better chance than this, it's my fault, I lost, so the situation is urgent.
As you say, it's bad to recruit people, right? We've only just exchanged the Holy
Grail, and we have
n't even grown it yet.
I still don't want to finish saying that, but I don't understand it.
It's a
decision, it's a matter of decision.
the car
me
ana
hanan
me
5 inverse
kire
my brother's anxiety is not even my brother no my village
Ramiroo is the minimum requirement for this mission
daru
[music]